et drac la poste
[Musique]
bienvenue à l'hôtel trop subi
johnny s'est mis en quatre pour que
cette soirée soit inoubliable
hossa sont les autres
[Musique]
jouets bluebiz huppert merci mon gendre
auj
j'ai tout gâché génie mais de quoi tu
parles
ton père m'a jamais considéré comme un
membre de la famille tout ça parce que
je suis pas un monstre donc tu veux
devenir un monstre est à 20 helsing le
rayon strify catr transforme les humains
en monstres et les montres en humain
c'est pas dangereux me duval quelqu'un
c'est chelou il s'est rien passé
idrac la pêche jauni
[Musique]
enfin mon cauchemar prend fin je suis de
nouveau humain
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce que vous voulez
orange devient chaud
vous avez vu mon père
au nom
nyon
drac
non nous on monte un humain et je suis
un monstre on doit rectifier ça embête à
six prime est de papeete
[Musique]
le soleil
dim en m'appelant risque absolument rien
et les majestueux il est merveilleux
il me blesse
ouais
[Musique]